Angel Reese is so famous that she can no
longer attend classes in person at LSU
in a recent interview with teenboat
Angel revealed that because of the fame
she got with winning a national title
she has opted to take online classes she
said being on campus was a bit too much
and she isn't the only athlete at LSU
who's doing this Libby Dunn also takes
online classes for safety reasons
because there were some scares in the
past and just like Livy Angel is
absolutely celebrity caliber she signed
multiple nil deals is racking in
millions of followers she's appeared in
a cardi B music video through the first
pitch at an Oilers game and more she
said she doesn't feel like a celebrity
but she says a lot of people look at her
as one because of her impact not only on
women's basketball but on Sports and
black women overall at the end of the
day Angel says that schools first in
basketball second end with the amount
she's getting recognized on campus she
knows what she has to do in order to
keep her priorities straight